what do you see in terms of the way they
fuel themselves it's like the biggest
error sticking to one one style of
feeding regardless of the training style
that they're engaging in so MMA athletes
they have to do high-intensity training
sessions strength and conditioning they
have to be doing sparring they have to
be doing pads rounds that are crazy hard
in every athlete each one is going to
have a different intensity relative to
their body type and so if somebody's
doing pads it's a 9 or a 10 out of 10 in
terms of intensity and they're doing
that fasted or they're doing that
without carbohydrates available to do
that work they can't they can't a hit
those training intensities repeatedly
and then they can't adapt as a response
to that training so they end up just
getting slower and more beat up instead
of faster and more powerful so if
they're doing high-intensity we need to
fuel the body in this specific way that
supports that training effort and then
the longer turn adaptation to that bow
additionally if they're doing low
intensity we can adjust our fueling
strategies based on what that dictates
you know if it's if it's a kind of a
base aerobic training session or if
they're doing skills and drills we want
to be feeding the body to adapt
differently than if they're doing the
high intensity sparring strengthen
conditioning or pads or whatever that
might be so for every athlete we're
looking at how their body uses substrate
energy the energy that they're using the
substrate between carbs and fat at each
of these intensities and then we also
need a base at base we need to base our
recommendations on where their body fits
into the division if they're if they're
20% out from their weight division four
weeks out then we're gonna have a little
bit of a more aggressive strategy
nutritionally because if weight becomes
a primary factor if they're ten percent
out four weeks out then we're gonna have
a little bit of a different conversation
and prioritization around the fueling
strategies and all of these
conversations integrate within our
strength conditioning program so that
we're working in concert and tying in
the workload in into our own system as
well as the training load that they're
engaging with with their skill specific
training now when you vary the diet that
you give them independent of the workout
what is it what is that based on is that
based on a hard accepted science of
carbohydrate versus
versus official fat essential fatty
acids like how do you determine that so
we use a philosophy a system called
metabolic efficiency you could call
metabolic flexibility I've heard it
called as well
and essentially the body will use
different substrate at different
intensities and at low intensities and
at rest the body can and likely should
be adapted for our for our sports
athletes too too fat at rest now it
depends on the sport type again if we're
a shot footer or if we're a hundred
meter sprinter then we're going to be
much more dependent on carbohydrates and
really the creatine phosphate system
we're not even getting into the
glycolytic system and Duncan could talk
a lot more about the energy systems but
essentially we're reliant upon glucose
and ATP for energy at the lower
intensity bursts right so to hit
repeated max or sub max efforts we
require blood sugar and without it we
will deplete our initial stores and then
we can't we can't we can no longer hit
90 or 95% of our max we start hitting 80
and 70 and 60 and in diminishing our
ability to do these high-intensity
efforts now do you guys see anybody come
in and try to fight on a ketogenic diet
cuz I know quite a few guys we're doing
that for a while I know Bryan caraway
did it Matt Brown yeah that's right he
has fought but he varies and I think he
yeah well I talked to him I think he did
one pretty pure and then he did you know
he did the one where you you know you
might take in sixty or eighty carbs but
then you were come off in the state
kitchen I don't mhm
some of those guys like Zack bitter he's
a altra marathon runner he he there he
does eat ketogenic most the time but
then on days of big races he'll consume
a lot of sugars yeah and yeah and again
all insulin sensitivity - yeah so
essentially the the more we could
regulate blood sugar at rest and low
intensities then we can expand and to
support the development of that kind of
aerobic oxidative system and by adapting
to use fat as a primary substrate we're
doing a number of things one we're
balancing blood sugar at rest so that we
can really limit the insulin spikes and
and essentially adipose development in
addition to really driving the body
towards the
date of and/or the Ox date of aerobic
system and then as we increase in what
we do is we assess how the body adapts
so through the training intensities and
we'll repeat that kind of on a monthly
basis to see how the athlete changes and
then as they increase in the intensity
of a training effort then we will adjust
the ratio of fat to carbohydrates as as
this as a fuel substrate